The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi.
Last time, you
may recall that we
were looking at
some of our examples
in three-dimensional
space and talking
about picking a
couple of vectors
in three-dimensional space, be
they i and j or alpha and beta.
And we then talked
about the subspaces
spanned by alpha and beta or
the subspace span by i and j,
noticing that the
subspace could be smaller
than the entire space.
Or possibly, it could even
equal the entire space.
In no event could it be
greater than the entire space.
At any rate, what we
would like to do today
is to generalize this
idea into more than two
or three dimensions.
And also, to make
the generalization
go independently of
our n-tuple notation
that we used earlier
in the course.
At any rate, today's
lesson is entitled,
Spanning Vectors,
and the idea is this.
Let's suppose we have
a vector space, v,
and we now arbitrarily choose n
vectors, alpha 1 up to alpha n
and v. For example,
in the lecture
last time, some of our
examples involved v
being three-dimensional
space and n being two.
In other words, we picked
i and j, alpha and beta,
in three-dimensional space.
But at any rate,
what we do is this.
We take alpha 1 up to alpha
n, any n arbitrarily chosen,
vectors, n, v, and we look
at the set, which I write
s of alpha 1 up to alpha n.
We look at the set of all
linear combinations of alpha 1
up to alpha n.
And written compactly,
that's written this way.
In other words, it's a c1 alpha
1 plus, et cetera, cn alpha n.
Where the cs are real
numbers, they belong to r.
Now, my claim is that this
set is more than a set.
It's a space.
Namely, if you of two linear
combinations of alpha 1
up to alpha n, you get a
linear combination of alpha 1
up to alpha n.
If you take a scalar multiple of
a linear combination of alpha 1
up to alpha n, you, again, get
up to alpha n.
Algebraically, this
is quite simple,
because structurally
we mimic what's
happening in ordinary algebra.
And what we're
saying is, you can
add the two alpha 1
components together,
the alpha 2 components
together, et cetera.
I'll illustrate that in a
simple example in a moment,
but the idea is this.
What we say is, by definition--
and we've done this in some
of the exercises already,
you'll recall--
that the subspace consisting
of all linear combinations
of alpha 1 up to alpha n,
which is a subspace of v,
it's called the space spanned
by alpha 1 up to alpha n.
That's all this thing means.
The space spanned by
alpha 1 up to alpha n
means the set of all linear
combinations of alpha 1
up to alpha n, and that
is a subspace of v.
For example, the easiest
case I can think of
is to pick n equals 1, given
a vector space, v, simply pick
any elements, say alpha
1, that belongs to v.
And all linear combinations
of alpha 1 are simply what?
All scalar multiples of alpha 1.
In other words, the
space spanned by alpha 1
is just a set of all
constant multiples of alpha.
So c alpha 1, where
c is a real number.
Now, my claim is that, clearly,
the sum of any two scalar
multiples of alpha 1 is a
scalar multiple of alpha 1.
And a scalar multiple of a
scalar multiple of alpha 1
is, again, a scalar
multiple of alpha 1.
I'd like to show you that,
though, independently
of a geometric interpretation.
This follows clearly from
our axiomatic approach,
namely, suppose
beta and gamma are
any two elements in the
space spanned by alpha 1.
That means beta is a
scalar multiple as alpha 1,
say c1 alpha 1.
Gamma is a scalar multiple
of alpha 1, say c2 alpha 1.
Therefore, beta plus gamma is
c1 alpha 1 plus c2 alpha 1.
By our distributive
property, that's
c1 plus c2 times alpha 1.
But since c1 and
c2 a real numbers,
and the sum of two real numbers
is, again, a real number,
we see that beta plus
gamma is a real number
times alpha 1, in other words,
a scalar multiple of alpha 1.
And that means that
by definition it
belongs to the space
spanned by alpha 1.
Similarly, if we take beta and
multiply it by the real number
r, r times c1 alpha 1, by
the associated property
for scalar multiplication,
is the scale of multiple r
times c1 times alpha 1.
And if r and c1 are real
number, so is their product.
So consequently, r times beta
is a scalar times alpha 1,
which by definition means
it's in the space spanned
by alpha 1.
And geometrically, if you want
to see what this thing means,
notice that the space
spanned by alpha 1--
if you want think of
alpha 1 as an arrow--
the space spanned by
alpha 1 is simply what?
The set of all linear
combinations of alpha--
all scalar multiples of alpha
1, and that is precisely
the straight line
determined by alpha 1.
In other words, any
linear combination--
any scalar multiple
of alpha 1 has what?
The same direction as alpha 1.
In other words, lies
in the same direction,
but may have a
different magnitude
and/or a different sense.
But certainly, the line
part doesn't change.
Now, the key point
is this, and this
is going to play a very key
role throughout the remainder
of our discussion.
One would believe
that the more vectors
you take linear combinations of,
the bigger your space becomes.
In other words, if you
take the space spanned
by two vectors, then tack
onto those two vectors
a third vector,
you might believe
that the resulting space must be
larger than the original space.
Well, obviously, it
can't be any smaller,
and I'll explain what
obviously means in the moment,
if it's not that obvious.
But the key point is, that
if I take not just alpha
1 up to alpha n, but
an additional vector,
say, alpha 1 up to alpha n plus
the additional vector alpha
n plus 1, and look at the
space spanned by alpha 1
through alpha n plus
1, that space need not
be larger than the space spanned
by alpha 1 up to alpha n.
In other words, merely by
tacking on a new vector,
you do not necessarily
tack on to the space
spanned by the vectors.
By means of a trivial example,
let alpha 1 be i, let alpha 2
be j, an alpha 3 be i plus j.
Clearly, the space spanned
by alpha 1 and alpha 2
is by definition this sort
of all linear combinations
of alpha 1 alpha 2.
And in terms of this
simple example, that
obviously is the x, y plane,
because alpha 1 is i, alpha 2
as j.
Now, let's look at the space
spanned by alpha 1, alpha 2,
and alpha 3.
Again, geometrically, notice
that that space is still
the x, y plane.
Because after all, alpha
1, alpha 2, and alpha 3,
being i, j, and i plus
j, respectively, all
lie in the x, y plane.
Consequently, any linear
combination of them
will lie in the x, y plane.
But let's pretend
we didn't know that.
Let's, first of all, observe
that from the pure mathematics
of this alone, that the space
spanned by alpha 1 alpha 2
must be a subspace of the space
spanned by alpha 1, alpha 2,
an alpha 3.
And the proof, by the
way, is quite trivial.
Namely, by definition,
the space spanned
by alpha 1, alpha
2, alpha 3 is a set
of all linear combinations
of alpha 1, alpha 2, alpha 3.
In particular, if I
choose c3 to equal 0,
notice that this term drops out.
And in particular,
what I'm left with
is c1 alpha 1 plus c2 alpha 2.
In other words, every linear
combination of alpha 1
and alpha 2 is, in particular,
a linear combination of alpha 1,
alpha 2, and alpha 3.
But my claim is, just as
we saw geometrically--
let me now prove
this algebraically--
that in particular, if beta
is any vector belonging
to the space spanned by alpha
1, alpha 2, and alpha 3,
axiomatically, it must belong
to the space spanned by alpha 1
and alpha 2.
We see that geometrically.
We already know that the
space is still the x, y plane.
How would we prove
this axiomatically?
Well, if beta belongs to
this space, by definition
it's a linear combination as
alpha 1, alpha 2, alpha 3.
Noticing, that alpha 3
is by definition alpha 1
plus alpha 2.
I can replace alpha 3
by alpha 1 plus alpha 2.
I can now distribute c3
with alpha 1 and alpha 2.
I can now combine the alpha
1 terms and the alpha 2 terms
together.
In other words, c1 plus c3
alpha 1 plus c2 plus c3 alpha 2.
Notice, that since
c1, c2, and c3
are real numbers, c1 plus c3
is the real number. c2 plus c3
is a real number.
Consequently, beta is a
linear combination of alpha 1
and alpha 2.
Therefore, beta is in the space
spanned by alpha 1 and alpha 2.
Therefore, the space spanned by
alpha 1, alpha 2, and alpha 3
is a subspace of the space
spanned by alpha 1 and alpha 2.
And since each of the subspaces
is a subspace of the other,
we see that these
two spaces happen
to be equal in this sense.
And by the way,
if you're looking
for a very quick way of seeing
how this transcends such
a simple application,
notice that when
we were dealing with
differential equations,
we looked for solutions that
were linearly independent.
In other words, we
wanted solutions
that could not be expressed
as linear combinations
of the previous solutions.
And the reason for
that was, if they
could be expressed this
way, the arbitrary constants
weren't independent in the sense
that they could be amalgamated.
At any rate, whichever
interpretation you want here,
notice that this leads to
a generalized definition.
Namely, given the n vectors,
alpha 1 up to alpha n and v,
they are called
linearly dependent.
Now, this may look
like a messy expression
that might frighten you.
All this says is they're called
linearly dependent if one
of the vectors can be written
as a linear combination
of the others.
And by the way, without
proving it here, but leaving
that for the exercises, it
can be shown that not only
when this can be done,
but when it can be done,
the vector can be written
as a linear combination
of the vectors that came before.
In other words, if
any vector, when you
list these in any order, if any
one of the vectors in the given
order can be expressed in
terms of a linear combination
of the preceding
ones, then the set
is called linearly dependent.
If this can't
happen, then they are
called linearly independent.
Now, the reason I give this
definition first-- it's
a bad definition,
because it seems
to depend on the order in
which I list the vectors.
The reason I give
this definition first
is because, I think,
intuitively, it's
easier to see.
In a moment, I will give
you a different definition
that's equivalent to this one.
But first, let me exploit this
fairly intuitive definition.
By means of an
example, suppose I'm
given the four vectors, i plus
j, i minus j, 5i plus j, and i
plus j plus k.
My claim is that
these four vectors
form a linearly-dependent
set, because, in particular,
in the given order,
5i plus j can
be expressed as a linear
combination of i plus j and i
minus j.
Namely, 5i plus j is three
times the first vector here, i
plus j, plus 2 times the
second vector, i minus j.
By the way, in the
next lecture, we'll
show how you pick off these
coefficients very quickly,
but we'll let that
go until next time.
For now, all that's
important is notice
that this vector is a linear
combination of these two.
Notice, by the way,
you could have said,
but couldn't you express i minus
j as a linear combination of i
plus j and 5i plus j?
The answer is, yes.
In other words, if I had written
the 5i plus j and the i minus j
in an interchanged
order, notice that it
would be i minus
j that would have
been a linear combination
of i plus j and 5i plus j.
That's why this is kind
of a hazy definition.
It seems to depend on the
order in which the vectors are
written.
A more conventional
definition is the following.
And just to show you that
dependence and independence are
themselves independent, meaning
you can start with either one,
let me give you an
equivalent definition,
but now stressing linear
independence instead.
Namely, notice that, if I
pick all 0 coefficients,
in other words, 0 alpha 1 plus
a set with 0 alpha n, obviously,
that linear combination
will add up to 0.
If that's the only way you can
make a linear combination add
up to 0, then the
vectors are said
to be linearly independent.
In other words,
alpha 1 up to alpha n
are called linearly
independent if the only way
that a linear combination
of them can equal 0
is if every coefficient is 0.
Again, keep in mind that
the converse is trivial.
If every coefficient is 0,
then, obviously, this will be 0.
For linearly-independent
vectors what we're saying is,
the only way this can be 0 is
if all the coefficients are 0.
And again, to emphasize
linear dependence,
what that would mean is what?
That the vectors would
be linearly dependent
if you could find a
linear combination,
c1 alpha 1 plus, et cetera,
cn alpha n equal to 0,
where at least one of the
cs was not equal to 0.
Now, I'm going to stress
that in the exercises.
This stuff is so new to
many of you, I believe,
that it's very, very difficult
to teach it in great depth
during a lecture.
I think it has to be kept on
a fairly superficial level,
leaving additional
details to the exercises.
Rather than hammer home
these exercises now,
let's simply point out
that linear dependence
implies redundancy.
In other words, if
one of the vectors
can be expressed as linear
combination of the others,
it can be deleted when you're
talking about a set of spanning
vectors.
In other words, going
back to our example
of the space spanned by
alpha 1 up to alpha n,
there are no redundancies
if the alphas
happen to be independent.
But if they're
dependent, it means
that any vector which
can be expressed
as a linear combination
of the others
can be deleted without
losing anything in the space.
And I'll show you that in
terms of other examples later.
But let me show what that means
from another point of view
also that I want to bring
out later in the lecture,
and that is another key point.
That if the alphas happen to
be linearly independent, then
if beta belongs to the
space spanned by the alphas,
not only can beta be written
as a linear combination
of the alphas, but
it can be done so
in one and only one way.
In other words, to say
this in a different form,
if the alphas are linearly
independent, if beta belongs
to the space spanned
by the alphas,
it has a unique representation
as a linear combination
of the alphas.
And what that means from
another point of view
is, that if the alphas
are linearly independent,
the only way that two linear
combinations can be equal
is if they are equal
coefficient by coefficient.
By the way, that was a
technique that we used
in undetermined coefficients.
And again, that shows
you why functions,
like the exponential, sine,
and cosine, et cetera,
tie-in with this generalized
definition of a vector space.
That all of these
things have applications
far beyond any interpretation
due to arrows alone.
But the proof of
something like this,
given that these two linear
combinations are equal,
simply transpose and
collect like terms,
which we can do
algebraically by the axioms
that we're permitted
to work with here.
If we group these
terms, we get this.
Since the alphas are
linearly independent,
the only way a linear
combination can be 0
is if each of the
coefficients is 0.
That means, in particular,
that a1 minus b1
must be 0, et cetera, up
to an minus bn being 0.
And that says, in
addition, what?
That a1 must equal b1,
et cetera, an equals bn,
and that verifies the claim,
that if the alphas are
independent,
linearly independent,
then two different
sets of coefficients
must lead to two
different vectors.
In terms of example
two, you see, notice
that alpha 3 was a linear
combination of alpha 1
and alpha 2.
Remember, alpha 3 was
alpha 1 plus alpha 2.
Notice that, therefore,
I can express alpha 3
in more than one way as a
linear combination of alpha 1,
alpha 2, and alpha 3.
For example, certainly alpha
3 is 0 alpha 1 plus 0 alpha 2
plus 1 alpha 3.
That's just alpha 3.
On the other hand, since
alpha 1 plus alpha 2
is alpha 3, and 1 alpha 1
is alpha 1 and 1 alpha 2
is alpha 2, notice
that alpha 3 can also
be written as 1 alpha 1 plus
1 alpha 2 plus 0 alpha 3.
See, the alphas were linearly
dependent in this example.
Notice that this allows
me to express alpha 3
as two different linear
combinations of alpha 1,
alpha 2, and alpha 3.
By the way, it's
not just these two.
There are instantly many
different ways I can do this.
Namely, since alpha 3
is alpha 1 plus alpha 2,
pick c to be an
arbitrary constant,
and look at the expression c
alpha 1 plus c alpha 2 times
1 minus c alpha 3.
If I expand this, this becomes
c alpha 1 plus c alpha 2
minus c alpha 3.
That's minus c alpha
1 plus alpha 2.
That cancels, and all
I have left is alpha 3.
In other words, alpha 3 can be
written in infinitely many ways
as a linear combination of
alpha 1, alpha 2, and alpha 3,
because the alphas were
linearly dependent.
At any rate, again,
let me emphasize,
I'll drill on this
with the exercises.
What I'd like to do now
is revisit the concept
of dimension, which
we treated in terms
of n-tuples in terms
of spanning vectors
and linear independence.
Namely, let's suppose I
have any vector space now,
not necessarily one written
in terms of n-tuples.
Let's suppose that this other
vectors and the 0 vector
in the vector space,
because, after all,
if the only vector in the
vector space is the 0 vector,
it's not a very
exciting vector space.
So let me assume that
I have something other
than a 0 vector in here.
Let me pick any non-zero vector
in v. Let me call it alpha 1.
And I now-- look at the
space-- span by alpha 1.
Clearly, that's a subspace of v.
On the other hand--
or not on the other hand.
Well, on the other
hand, this might
be all of v. If the space
spanned by alpha 1 is all of v,
we stop at that point and
say, v is one-dimensional,
and it's spanned by the
single vector, alpha 1.
On the other hand, suppose s,
the space spanned by alpha 1,
it's not all of v. Well,
what does that mean?
It means there must
be a vector, say alpha
2, which belongs to v, but
not to the space spanned
by alpha 1.
Well, what we do now is
augment alpha 1 by alpha 2.
And we now look at the space
spanned by alpha 1 and alpha 2.
The first thing I claim is that
the space spanned by alpha 1
and alpha 2 is a proper
superspace of the space spanned
by alpha 1.
In other words, it's a
space spanned by alpha 1.
It's contained in but not equal
to the space spanned by alpha 1
and alpha 2.
Why is this?
Well, for one thing,
alpha 2 by definition
didn't belong to the
space spanned by alpha 1.
See, we picked alpha 2 not
to be in the space spanned
by alpha 1.
On the other hand, alpha 2 does
belong to the space spanned
by alpha 1 and alpha 2.
You see, notice that the space
spanned by alpha 1 and alpha 2
consists of all linear
combinations of alpha 1
and alpha 2, and in
particular, alpha 2
can be written as 0
alpha 1 plus 1 alpha
2, which makes it a linear
combination of alpha 1
and alpha 2.
So alpha 2 does not belong to
the space spanned by alpha 1,
but it does belong to the space
spanned by alpha 1 and alpha 2.
Notice, therefore, that we
have now enlarged our space.
Notice also that alpha 1 alpha
2 must be linearly independent.
In other words, we
chose any alpha 2,
provided only that it belonged
to v but not to the space
spanned by alpha 1.
But that alpha 2, no
matter how we choose it,
must be linearly
independent of alpha 1,
because, after all, if they
were linearly dependent,
that would mean that alpha 2 is
a scalar multiple as alpha 1.
But that's a contradiction,
because if alpha 2 were
a scalar multiple of
alpha 1, by definition
it would belong to the
space spanned by alpha 1.
But we specifically chose it
not to belong to that space.
At any rate, we
continue on in this way.
Namely, the space spanned
by alpha 1 and alpha 2
might be all of v,
in which case we then
say v is two-dimensional and
that it's spanned by alpha 1
and alpha 2.
Or it may be that the space
spanned by alpha 1 and alpha 2
is a proper subset of v and
doesn't give me all of v.
In this event, I
now pick an alpha 3,
which belongs to v, but not to
the space spanned by alpha 1
and alpha 2.
Again, notice that alpha
1, alpha 2, and alpha 3
must be linearly independent
since if alpha 3 could
be expressed as a linear--
see, we know alpha
2 can't be expressed
as a linear
combination of alpha 1,
because alpha 2 was linearly
independent of alpha 1.
Now we tack on alpha 3.
The only possibility is is
alpha 3 a linear combination
of alpha 1 and alpha 2?
And the answer is,
it couldn't be.
Because if alpha 3 were a
linear combination of alpha 1
and alpha 2, by
definition it would
belong to the space spanned
by alpha 1 and alpha 2.
But by construction, alpha 3 was
chosen not to be in that space.
Consequently, if alpha
3 were in that space,
that would obviously
be a contradiction.
In other words, alpha 3
cannot be a linear combination
of alpha 1 and alpha 2.
Therefore, these three vectors
are linearly independent.
And similarly, alpha 3,
not belonging to the space
spanned by alpha 1 and
alpha 2, enlarges the space
spanned by alpha 1 and alpha 2.
In terms of a
rough picture here,
what we're saying is, we start
with some vector, alpha 1.
s of alpha 1 is some subspace.
We put an alpha 2, which doesn't
belong to the space spanned
by alpha 1.
Then the space spanned
by alpha 1 and alpha 2
is this larger
subspace, which contains
the space spanned by alpha 1.
If that isn't all of v, we
pick a third vector, alpha 3,
which isn't in the space
spanned by alpha 1 and alpha 2.
And we then form the space
spanned by alpha 1, alpha 2,
and alpha 3, which will contain
the space spanned by alpha 1
and alpha 2 as a subspace.
And to make a long story short,
we simply continue in this way
until we find alpha
1, say, up to alpha n.
In other words, we continue
for n steps this way,
such that v will eventually be
the space spanned by alpha 1
up to alpha n.
And let me emphasize that
this need not happen.
In other words, v might be
such a huge vector space,
that continuing in this way,
we could go on forever and not
exhaust all of v this way.
But suppose, for the
sake of argument,
that this does happen,
that we find n alphas such
that v is spanned by
alpha 1 up to alpha n,
where the alphas
are constructed,
as I've indicated previously.
In this case, we say that v has
dimension n written this way,
and the set of vectors,
alpha 1 up to alpha n,
is called a basis
for v. And the reason
that it's called the basis
for v is that not only can
every vector be written
as a linear combination
of the alphas, every
vector in v written
as a linear combination
of the alphas,
but it has a unique
representation
in terms of the alphas,
because the alphas were
linearly independent.
In other words, once you have a
basis, you see, any vector in v
can be written uniquely
as an n-tuple where
the coefficients stand for
the coefficients of alpha 1
up to alpha n.
You see, in other
words, each v and v
has a unique representation,
unique representation,
as a linear combination
of alpha 1 up to alpha n.
By the way, if this process
doesn't come to an end,
then v is set to be an
infinite-dimensional vector
space.
Now, what I'd like to do is
take a few minutes to summarize
this particular lecture.
Because what we're going
to be doing between now
and the next lecture is going
to involve a lot of work
on your part.
And that is, that in going
through this overview of what
you mean by dimension, and
spanning sets, and what
have you, and linear
dependence and independence,
many subtleties have occurred.
For example, if I have an
n-dimensional vector space
going through this bit of
constructing the space spanned
by alpha--
alpha 1 and alpha 2, et
cetera-- questions come up.
What if I had started
with different vectors?
What if I had started with
beta 1 instead of alpha 1,
and then picked a new vector,
beta 2 instead of alpha 2?
Could I have spanned v
in fewer than n vectors?
In other words,
does the dimension
depend on the process by
which I span the space by how
I choose the vectors?
Obviously, if this happens to
be true, we're in dire trouble.
Because we would like
to believe intuitively,
based on our old
definition of dimension,
that the dimension
of a vector space
should not depend on
the representative
vectors that you pick.
This is what's bad about
the n-tuple representation.
So you see, what we're going
to do in the exercises is show
what other ingredients
come up in dimension
and what we have to worry about.
In our next lecture, we
will summarize the results
that we will prove
in the exercises.
So you can begin
the next lecture
even if you're a little bit
hazy on some of the exercises.
And then we will show, from
a practical point of view,
once the theory is
developed, how do we actually
go about constructing a basis.
How do we find what a
dimension is in real life?
How do we figure out how to
construct the alphas if we're
not given the abstract
situation mentioned
in this particular example?
At any rate, all I want to
do now is review the lecture,
do the exercises, start to
feel at home with the concepts,
and we will drill more on this
and review in our next lecture.
At any rate, then,
until next time.
Goodbye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.